[Musik]
ich habe einen leitsatz
das leben ist zu kurz um dinge zu tun
die man nicht mag
seit ich bei air zermatt bin wollte ich
noch nie blau machen
die air zermatt familie beflügelt mich
ja wo bist du ich bin gleich da
wir sind eng verbunden wie brüder
[Musik]
wir sind freunde und kollegen das
gefällt mir alle arbeiten für das
gleiche ziel
[Musik]
in der hochsaison sind die
arbeitsreichsten tage das ist für alle
ziemlich stressig man muss das drehen
mit dem kleineren teil nach innen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
beginnt im büro wo die anrufe der
rettungsleitstelle eingehen
die unfall hier oben auf der piste
männlicher patienten mit
rückenverletzungen
in tänikon setzt sich fort über die
flughäfen die sanitäter die ärzte bis
hin zu den piloten
[Musik]
was ist los rettungseinsatz wie viele
hehl ich sind da
okay wie lange geht das bis mittag
ist das genau
[Musik]
in der hochsaison fliegen wir manchmal
20 einsätze pro tag von zwei standorten
aus
[Musik]
brauchte fuchs
wir brauchen mehrere standorte denn
unser einsatzgebiet ist so groß dass wir
es von einer basis aus nicht abdecken
könnte
kalt es ist kalt
mühsam
da oben ist sowie wäre mir zu dumm wären
vier ampullen so was bestellt stoff net
java euch das ist ja blödsinn ich vier
ampullen bestellen zu wollen
axel ist einzigartig du als solange
tätiger im rettungsdienst weißt doch
dass man mit vier einzel ampullen
bestellen kann die denken dort oben wir
wären die größten idioten ist relax
bühne er ist sehr erfahren
ich vertraue ihm er weiß beim einsatz
genau was er tut aber wenn du einen
fehler gemacht hast dann geh lieber
entdeckung vor ihm
ich wollte jetzt sind noch sorgen
vorwärts laufen nicht rückwärts
[Applaus]
ein pieks während der hochsaison kommen
35.000 besucher davon allein ins heimat
bis zu 18.000 skifahrer pro tag
da kann man sich vorstellen wie
anstrengend die hochsaison ist
wenn sich so viele menschen in den
bergen aufhalten kommt es natürlich auch
zu unfällen und damit zu
rettungseinsätzen manchmal gehen
innerhalb von minuten gleich mehrere
anrufe ein und dann kann es schwierig
werden
[Musik]
die uns so sehr mit aladdin vita-x
möglich
[Musik]
fast 2000 einsätzen pro jahr sind die
fälle sehr unterschiedlich
die verletzungen reichen von leichten
knochenbrüchen über schwere frakturen
bis hin zu gehirnerschütterung
kindern ist das meist schwer zu ertragen
besonders wenn man selbst welche hat
denkt man über die eigene familie nach
[Musik]
die französisch ist ein gut das zu
schmerzen
ich drücke mal auf deinen rücken tut es
weh
weiter unten
als ich sie mit dem gesicht nach unten
liegen sah dachte ich sofort an eine
verletzung der wirbelsäule
wenn jemand mit dem gesicht im schnee
liegt stimmt irgendwas nicht
wenn jemand so daliegt weiß man dass er
keine show abzieht das mädchen war 13
fast noch ein kind
wir dachten zuerst dass sie womöglich
gelähmt wäre
im alter von dreizehn ist das schwer zu
verkraften
[Musik]
du kannst du deine füße spüren
wie weh tut es auf einer skala von 1 bis
du bekommst links eine kleine spritze
sobald sie wirkt drehen wir dich auf den
rücken und dann bringen wir dich ins
krankenhaus nach bern ja
ganz vorsichtig stopp
genauso perfekt
schon sagte sagte
alles gut
na bitte sehr gut
perfekt ich nehme dir jetzt den helm ab
er ist gut
holen
von diesem moment an zählte jede minute
sie musste dringend ins krankenhaus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
alle
[Musik]
eigentlich besteht
weil dann in die wendig in der luft bin
kann ich wirklich entspannen
das ist es was ich am meisten liebe
hubschrauber fliegen
ich schau rein
raus rein und raus
rein schauen mit dem linken auge
rausschauen mit dem rechten das nennt
man multitasking darin bin ich gut
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
was es passiert können sie mir das
okay wenn du selbst nicht weiß kann ja
dann ist es nicht schlimm weil es kann
auch passieren wenn du auf den kopf
heißt
es gibt einen kleinen stopp fand
erschrecken gott
was habe ich gemacht du willst was
eigentlich auf den kopf gefallen war
wichtig dass ich
bin von der rettung was machen schmerzen
wir sind dafür die wir sind wirklich
dafür
[Musik]
du bist gestellt
ich mache
jetzt hörst du mal zu jetzt muss man
moment liege bleibe im helly machen wir
alles wieder auf einstand
[Musik]
niemand geht gern die kontrolle ab es
ist schwer jemanden zu vertrauen den man
noch nie gesehen hat und der noch dazu
keinen roten bart trägt
[Musik]
in solchen momenten ist es wichtig den
leuten zu vermitteln dass die kontrolle
in guten händen ist und
das kommt schon gut jetzt kommt der
hubschrauber und dann gehen sie werden
du bist
alles stabil
das fehlt mir denn sie waren höhenkrank
bleiben sie einfach liegen wir helfen
ihnen
mein moment langsam
das tut ihnen gut ist sauerstoff
ok
wenn man nicht an die höhe gewöhnt ist
schlägt das herz schneller und man kann
kopfschmerzen bekommen 12
dies sind anzeichen dass man seine
grenzen erreicht ohne dass vieles merken
dadurch kommt es häufig zu unfällen aber
wir helfen den menschen jeden tag
kinder sind unschuldig also hofft man
dass die verletzung nicht so schlimm ist
wie sie sein könnte
wir bringen elodie zu einem spezialisten
für wirbelsäulenverletzungen
die schlimmste diagnose wäre dass sie
gelähmt ist
es wäre wirklich hart
[Musik]
hallo
was hat
[Musik]
die spezialisten wissen nicht genau was
los ist
bei uns aber die knochen sind stabil die
wirbelsäule ist nicht gebrochen
sie hat schwellung doch nichts
ungewöhnliches sie hat sich gestoßen das
ist alles
[Musik]
man kann ganz kurz
ronja
du hast am 14 august geburtstag
ich habe nächste kleine york
das ist immer gut
die sky jungs lieben action sie sind
gern in der luft was drückst du dich da
herum
ich muss nur hier hoch dann bin ich bei
dir er ist verrückt
geben zwölf monate volle pulle und dann
sitzen sie auch mal zwei monate warten
auf dem boden herum
oben war starker wind aber wenn man ihn
laufen lässt stabilisierte sich von
allein
diese maschine ist ein traum
um bei erz heimat zu arbeiten muss man
das fliegen lieben und ein bisschen
verrückt sein
ich kenne robbie seit 30 jahren sogar
noch länger denn er wuchs in zermatt auf
er ist ein talent ein vogel er ist
definitiv einer der besten piloten die
ich je gesehen habe
mir gefällt es wenn viel los ist als
pilot möchte man immer fliegen
ich kann mir keinen anderen beruf
vorstellen
[Musik]
bereitet zu sein ist teil unseres lebens
wenn wir mittags zum essen zurückkommen
schalten wir ab und machen pause
[Musik]
aber auch wenn wir entspannen sind wir
im hinterkopf immer in bereitschaft
[Musik]
wir gehen sofort lesen
das kind
das könnte dir in einer minute sagen
das ist als wenn man die kuh im heli
fragt ist es windig und sie antworten
client
und sieht sich plaudert miteinander und
plötzlich innerhalb von 10 15 minuten
ist die basis menschenleer
[Musik]
susi gestartet wie ab etwa halb nach
lugano
der staudamm ist der fall
im schnitt liege
axel ist herausragend er hat unglaublich
viel erfahrung er gehört definitiv zu
den besten
[Musik]
wir sind froh sein sohn jetzt als
rettungssanitäter zu haben ich bin
sicher er wird ein guter
[Musik]
da bist du
das tut doch schnitt schloss
nach lehrer von lugano 1000 meter
richtung landeplatz
also gut
[Musik]
wir wurden eben über die grenze gerufen
das italienische skigebiet mit doch
jetzt
sieht ja wirklich einladend aus scheint
als hätten sie wiegen niebel geschlossen
sofort
war sofort hier sieht es aus als käme
der nebel auf uns zu
verstehen aber hier ist die sicht gut
alles klar ich denke sie können her
fliegen
[Musik]
wenn die wetterbedingungen so schlecht
sind dass man nicht sieht richten wir
uns normalerweise nach den instrumenten
aber
in den alpen und den engen tälern
funktioniert das nicht das macht den
einsatz extrem schwieriger
da kommen wir nicht durch
die frage ist ob wir wieder zurückkommen
wir versuchen einen weg zu ihnen zu
finden aber es sieht nicht gut aus
wegen der dichten wolkendecke konnten
wir nicht nach italien fliegen der
patient ist unter dem nebel
wir müssen unter den nebel kommen und
ihn abholen das wird etwas dauern
sehr gut
ja denn jetzt müssen wir warten
männlich 35 jahre kommission hatten 27
auf k
geschafft
fahrstuhl
[Musik]
und den
prozess vor der 13 ja genau wenn die
neue folge ich hätte noch einen folge
ein satz mit x wäre es möglich zu
bettmeralp zurückzufliegen
eine unter beinfraktur weiblich 40 fonds
zu vergrößern
ich habe verstanden messi sowie heute
morgen waren
da doch einfach wird
23 minuten da
[Musik]
woher kommst du
aus südafrika wir müssen sie den
rucksack abschneiden ist das in ordnung
da nicht bewegen bitte
geben sie ein betäubungsmittel du wirst
schlafen
ist wichtig dass wir leise unter
schlecht
es ist leichter für ihn wenn er von was
gut um die im urlaub träumt
kannst du mir einen gefallen tun ich
denke an etwas schönes denken
wegen des medikaments
nein
es schon mein alkohol getrunken
seine eltern hören nicht zu
es ist als würdest du zwei bier trinken
es tut ein bisschen weh wir wirklich war
du bist es warte bis du das erste mal
ausgeht ist das einzige was du von
teurem alkohol bekommst sind
kopfschmerzen
[Musik]
vor ein paar jahren traf ich eine nette
frau
[Musik]
für mich war sie die richtige
wir haben geheiratet
die hatte bekam zusammen ein kind
jetzt wirst du das war der beste moment
meines lebens
[Musik]
später hat sie mich verlassen und ist
nach deutschland zurückgekehrt
mit unserem sohn
die meiste ich ihn nur an einem
wochenende im monat er wohnt weit weg
und ich arbeite viel
jeden tag denke ich an ihn
ich frage mich immer wäre er stolz auf
das was ich heute geleistet habe
[Musik]
manchmal bleibt uns nichts anderes übrig
als auf besseres wetter zu warten
ich hasse das aber das gehört nun mal
zum job
aber das wetter wird das er
stimmte sieht besser aus
ja hallo hallo sind sie bereit dann los
packen wir es an
ok alles klar auf geht's kaum
[Musik]
bei 110 grad - bittet türen schließen es
gab noch mal
hörten auf pflanzen und samen
so sehen
rechte unterschenkel okay
als zehn grad minus
[Musik]
der welt
es ist kalt macht die tür zu
wir sind voll
[Musik]
für alle sind sollten mal
ran ich franken lokale zurückkommen hier
sitzt noch ein zweiter mann hat sich
dieser wunsch einen aktiven fließt du
kannst dir sagen dass ein bisschen
kribbelig
vorsicht etwas ins letzte kapitel bei
bislang
war mir heute eine ehre habe einfach
drauf passen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hallo hallo wir sind im spital in visp
alles klar danke
wir müssen noch mal nach wenn china was
haben wir da eine beinverletzung
warte hier ja
schwarzenbach dem skischuh
wartet in woche das einfach entspannen
ausgemacht
[Musik]
ich habe durch meinen sohn viel gelernt
besonders über die kommunikation mit
kindern es ist wichtig mit ihnen auf
augenhöhe zu reden
sie können mir in die augen sehen in
mein gesicht ich versuche sanitäter zu
sein aber auch eine art freund
[Musik]
2 prozent dort wird bald gestartet acht
minuten später
bei como
unterschenkelfraktur leblich
ihr habt zwei patienten fürs spital visp
angemeldet da gibt es einen
notfallpatienten verlegung nach sion
könnt ihr die übernehmen
schafft es so schön
[Musik]
damit findet heute einfach kein ende
der orbit kommen
von events geht's nicht weiter hat die
ganze werke zu hören
[Musik]
das so ist dann fließt und ganzen stimmt
ihre uniform im anflug 1000 meter
band flug auf speed asien
immer alles
protokoll brauchen sie nicht
was ist mit den schmerzen geht
gott und vorgestern sie das atmen nicht
[Musik]
wir hoffen alle dass der tag jetzt zu
ende ist
durch hart wir hatten heute sechs
einsätze
ich weiß nicht wie es bei den anderen
hieß war aber ich schätze wir kommen
insgesamt auf 25 einsätze
man fliegt den ganzen tag konzentriert
auf die arbeit fokussiert die vielen
landungen und starts erschöpfen sich
physisch aber
auch der kopf wird müde du musst die
ganze zeit aufpassen was du tust
[Musik]
man nimmt jeden tag wie er kommt du
versuchst einfach weiterzumachen mit der
arbeit der familie den freunden
[Musik]
es würde nicht funktionieren hätten die
menschen um dich herum kein verständnis
für diesen job
also das muss ja nicht sein der ärger
nach der pflege mal macht sagt tff
engagiert und dann heißt verlegung jetzt
kaum chancen
ein
wir starten gerade hier lassen kann
seien normal
spätestens in acht minuten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meine schicht ist zu ende
die war heute wirklich ungewöhnlich
normalerweise arbeiten wir nicht so
lange
[Musik]
bisweilen ist unser job schon seltsam
wir arbeiten lange und dann bleibt nicht
viel zeit für die familie
nach und nach wird die firma zu deiner
familie
wenn man rettungseinsätze fliegt lässt
man nicht um punkt fünf uhr den stift
fallen und sagt okay das war's
manchmal wirkt die arbeit stressig etwa
wenn das team sich gerade zum mittag
versammelt hat und schon wieder los muss
der streit in alle winde
aber man lernt mit diesem druck
umzugehen
das geheimnis ist dass man wie freunde
miteinander umgeht
[Musik]
gut aber etwas verkauft
an tagen wie diesem baut man mehr
selbstvertrauen auf als an anderen
ich freue mich dass unsere leute hoch
professionell arbeiten ich bin wirklich
sehr stolz auf das team
[Musik]
wir hatten acht rettungseinsätze wo ein
alter hut aber
[Musik]
klug am 8
von mir aus kann es die nacht ruhig
bleiben und auch schön aus
david stern
[Musik]
das beste an diesem job ist dass er am
nächsten tag wieder von vorne losgeht
und
wieder und wieder
nic
[Musik]